- You talked about, you
know, all the misinformation.
It's funny too.
'Cause this is the
other thing I take away
from Jen Psaki's comment.
They're the ones
identifying misinformation.
Well, how many times have
they been wrong on that?
Over the last 40,
they told us the protesters
were peaceful last summer.
They told us that Republicans
defunded the police.
They told us the
dossier was real.
They told us Trump
colluded with Russia.
Bob Mueller did a $30 million
investigation and said,
that's not accurate.
(soft music)
- I'm Dave Rubin.
And joining me today
is a Congressman
for Ohio's fourth district.
He serves as the ranking
member of the house judiciary
committee and is a co-founder
of the house freedom caucus,
Congressman Jim Jordan.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- It is good to
be with you, Dave,
and thank you for what you do.
Thank you for
fighting for freedom
and first amendment liberties
for our, for everyone.
And we, I mean, the
country appreciates that.
So good to be with you.
- Oh, well.
I appreciate the kind words.
I can bounce that
right back at you.
You were one of the leaders,
especially I think on
the big tech stuff,
fighting for free speech
and free expression
and keeping the
government and big tech
out of every little
facet of our lives.
So actually let's,
let's start right there.
- Sure.
- Big tech.
Well, I'll give you the
broad question first
and then we'll get
into the specifics.
Big tech, what do we do?
Do you want to regulate?
Do you want to break them up?
Do you believe
competition is enough?
Is it all of those?
Is it none of those?
- No. It's all of those
and probably some more.
I mean, I do think
you've got to get rid
of the liability protection,
the so-called section 230.
That's a start.
Then I think you have to give,
and we have a series of,
there'll be in bill form soon.
But ideas we're talking
about give her to 230,
private right of action.
Like big tech makes
some moderate,
content moderation
decision about you.
They got to tell you why,
and there needs to
be some training.
Why did they do that?
And frankly, if they do it
and like the DeSantis
did in Florida,
if you're a candidate for
office and they do those kinds
of things, there should
be a right of action,
you have to hold
them accountable.
So that's something
we're looking at.
And then frankly,
I think, you know, justice
Thomas has, I think,
more than hinted that he
wants to address this issue
and talking about big tech
and the power they have.
So what we're also looking
at doing is speeding up
the antitrust actions
in our court system.
So it gets to the Supreme
court and we can get an answer.
After all the Trump
administration,
both the FTC brought antitrust
action against Facebook and
the justice
department has brought
an antitrust action
against Google.
And we'll see how that all
shakes out with the Biden DOJ.
But I think that's where
it has to focus versus
what the Democrats are
talking about doing,
which is just giving
more power to the FTC,
which I think would translate
into big government colluding
with big tech to further
stick it to conservatives.
- Right, which is pretty much
what's happening already.
On the 230 point.
My audience is all they all
know about the difference
between platform and
publisher and all that.
The pushback on
getting rid of 230,
which I'm basically
for getting rid of it.
So I think we're pretty
much lined up there.
The pushback though,
is that if you get
rid of the protections
that basically all
of these platforms,
Twitter, YouTube,
Facebook, et cetera,
that they will have to sensor
more because they'll be
worried about the liability.
What would you say to that?
- Legitimate concern.
There's also the
concern that, you know,
they're so big, they
can handle the lawsuits
that come when they
do censor people
and versus the competition
that we want to have happen.
But I just think the fundamental
issue is, look, if they're,
if they're making publishing
decisions, editorial decisions,
they're not supposed to have
the liability protection.
And that's, we know that
that's what they're doing.
So I think you just
have to look at the,
sort of the fundamental
question, say, okay,
you're making those
editorial decisions.
you don't get the protection
and then go from there.
But that's why I think you
also need the other things
I talked about to
actually address this.
Again, what concerns me most is
in an effort to deal
with censorship.
We have, we have people
embracing this idea that, oh,
we got to give the
government, the bureaucracy,
the agencies more
regulatory power.
And I just think that's a mess.
And frankly, we just saw this.
We just saw this with Jen Psaki,
the spokesperson for the
president of the United States.
I mean, think about
what she said.
She said, big tech
are now where so many
people get their news,
ie they're the press.
And so she said,
we are working with the press
to stop certain information
from getting to we, the
people, the American people.
That is a direct violation of
their first amendment freedom
of the press liberties we have.
That's scary.
And they got some
list of 12 people
who they say are putting
out misinformation.
So there's that sort of
fundamental question.
I think that's, what's,
what the concern
is that marriage of big
government and big tech,
I think only means
conservatives, get it worse.
- When you hear Psaki say
something like that, her actual,
the word that to me was the,
where the real bell
went off was she said,
we flagged content for Facebook.
The implication is we're
doing it together, right.
We're flagging it for them.
When you hear that,
do you ever go to your
democratic counterparts
and go guys, look, we may
not agree on tax rates,
we may not agree on abortion
or blah, blah, blah.
But I thought we at least
agreed on first amendment stuff.
Do they, do they
take that meeting?
Do they take that call?
- They used to, I don't
know if they would now.
And frankly, I have my, I'm
skeptical they would now.
Because it has gotten
so, so partisan.
And we've had a
number of Democrats,
some of them on the
judiciary committee,
the committee that's
supposed to safeguard
the bill of rights,
the constitution,
and American's fundamental
rights and liberties.
We've had so many of
them cheer on big tech
when they sensor conservative.
So it's not the same.
It used to be that
you could work with.
I mean, I always make
this, tell this story.
Dennis Kucinich former
member is a friend of mine.
I mean, I talked to him
on the phone a few months.
I just texted him yesterday
'cause I saw him on a,
on a clip on Tucker.
Dennis is an old school
liberal who says,
let's make the best
arguments, have the debate.
And he was with us
on civil liberties.
But that's not where
today's left is.
Today's left is authoritarian
and you're seeing it
from the spokesperson
of the president of
the United States,
in the white house
briefing room.
So it's a different
animal today.
And again, I think that's
why you're so concerned
and I'm so concerned,
and so many Americans are
about what's really happening
to our freedoms.
- Yeah. You know Dennis Kucinich
is actually a perfect example.
When he ran for president,
which was, you know,
probably 16 years ago,
something like that.
He was the furthest left
Democrat at that point.
And basically the only people
who will talk to him now
are Tucker and Fox News.
They would never put him
on CNN at this point.
- And he was a
champion of civil.
We were on the oversight
committee together
when Democrats had power back,
when Dennis was in Congress.
He chaired this subcommittee
I was the ranking mem.
And when it flipped, I was
chairman, he was ranking member.
And there were issues where
we could work together.
Typically they were civil.
And like, we were both concerned
about facial
recognition technology
and how law enforcement might
use that to violate our.
So we could work together.
And when we didn't agree,
he was a true liberal,
like let's have the
debate, let's have the.
Get your best hold and
make your best argument.
Let's see who wins
after it's over,
we'll shake hands and we'll
get ready for the next issue
and have the debate.
That is so different
from what we see today,
where it's so the,
the vitriol and going after
people and the canceling
and everything else.
It is a completely
different animal.
I long for the,
for the people like like
Kucinich, like Dennis Kucinich,
who's a good man,
and believes in so many
of the same things we do
when it comes to
civil liberties.
Different on policy,
we're miles apart on
other policy issues.
But, you know, we need
more of that, frankly,
in the United States, Congress.
- I think I've
asked this question
to every Congressman or
Senator that I've had on,
and I'd love to
know your take too.
Do you know when,
do you have a moment
or was there a person
that you can point to
when the Democrats really
went off the deep end
with this stuff?
When it was okay, no more
talking, no more negotiating.
You guys are all
bad guys, Nazis,
whatever nonsense
they're throwing at you.
Do you remember
when it happened?
- Well, I mean,
I would probably point
to November 8th, 2016,
when Donald Trump got
elected president.
Because we know what
president Trump,
an individual by the
way who I think was,
did an amazing job as president.
Did more, of what he
said than any president,
certainly in my lifetime.
Accomplished so much
with relentless attacks
from the left and the
Democrats and the media,
and frankly, too
many Republicans,
and still got so much done.
But I think it
probably started then.
Now there may be something else.
But the first thing
that popped to mind was
the day he wins election
Democrats have been, you know,
going after him and continue
to do so now five years later.
- Yeah. And then of course,
there's that moment
when Rashida Tlaib,
the night she got
sworn in saying
she was going to impeach the
guy, years ago, years ago.
I think you have to have a
crime before the guilt, right?
- Right.
- If I'm not mistaken.
I'm a simple guy.
- Yeah. But then we also learn,
I mean, you think about it.
We learned that
the FBI was spying
on a presidential campaign.
Like that's not supposed to
happen in our great country.
A major party's political
or presidential candidate,
their campaign
was being spied on
by the other parties'
justice department,
ie the FBI Jim Comey.
I mean, that's scary.
And, Joe, you talk
about, you know,
all the misinformation.
It's funny too,
'cause this is the
other thing I take away
from, Jen Psaki's comment.
They're the ones
identifying mis-information.
Well, how many times have
they been wrong on that?
Over the last 40.
They told us the protestors
were peaceful last summer.
They told us that Republicans
defunded the police.
They told us the
dossier was real.
They told us Trump
colluded with Russia.
Bob Mueller did a $30
million investigation
and said that's not accurate.
They told us Trump cleared
Lafayette square for a photo op.
The inspector general
said, that's not true.
They told us.
How about this one, Hunter Biden
was Russian misinformation.
Holy cow, we had an
eyewitness, Tony Bobulinski.
We had actual
documents, the emails.
We had a laptop and we had
the FBI investigating it.
But somehow it was
Russian misinformation.
I mean, time and time again,
every major story they
told us was misinformation.
They lied to us about it.
And now they're the ones
telling Facebook, oh,
you got to take
down misinformation.
That's frightening.
I can add a couple to your list,
Brett Kavanaugh is a rapist,
the Covington kids,
Jessie Smollett.
I mean the list, the
list goes on and on.
So as you are seeing
Psaki say, okay,
we're flagging
things for Facebook,
or her other one last week,
which was even worse in a way.
Which was, if you're banned
from one social media site,
you should be banned from all
as if that has anything
to do with her,
with what her job is.
I mean, are you shocked?
Like, I think I, I'm
not shocked, right.
Like, I've been doing
this for a while.
I've been sensing and
warning about this stuff.
But I think a certain amount
of people are like, you know,
that voted for Biden because
they had whatever their
aversion was to Trump in
the tweets or whatever.
But I think a certain
amount of people actually
are shocked right now,
like how out of control
this thing feels.
- Yeah. I think
you're right, Dave.
You're not because you follow it
and you know, all these,
these issues so well.
And, frankly, most of us in,
in elective office, who've
been here, you know,
for a few years, we
shouldn't be shocked either.
'Cause we, we saw the trend,
we saw the IRS
target conservatives.
We saw what the FBI did
too with the dossier
and with the Trump campaign.
And we saw what they did with...
So we've seen all
this sort of progress.
So it's still frightening,
it's still scary.
But we sort of, kind of
saw some of this coming.
But I do think there
are lots of Americans
who are very nervous about
what they see
happening to liberty.
I'd talk with them in our,
I was back in our
district last week,
talking with
supporters and people.
They're very nervous
about what they see.
And how many times have you
gotten the line from someone
who follows you, you see them
at the airport or something.
They come up to you
and they'll say,
I'm really nervous about
our country can our country.
- [Dave] Oh yeah.
- 'Cause they Dave they love,
this country, they
love the flag,
they love what our
country stands for.
They love the people who
sacrifice for our country
and liberate the country
and took on the
Nazis and everything.
They love all that
appropriately so,
but they are nervous,
very nervous,
very concerned about where
the left wants to take us.
And that never used to,
that didn't happen 15
years ago in politics.
But now you, I get that every,
every time I'm
traveling to an airport.
- Right there used to
be a basic agreement.
that America was
fundamentally good.
And then it's like, okay,
we can argue from a liberal
perspective or a conservative.
Now, it's in essence,
should this thing continue.
BUt backing up to the big
tech stuff for a little bit.
So, breaking them up.
Let's let's talk about
that for a little bit.
What does that
actually look like?
Like you want Amazon basically
to have their server farm,
you know, AWS as
a separate company
than say the
consumer facing side
that we all buy our toilet
paper on or that sort of thing?
- What I think should happen is
we have historically done this.
We got a hundred years
of antitrust law.
We have historically done
this through the core process.
Now that is a slow process.
I would like to speed that
up because I see the danger
of big tech, and
I see, you know,
what we just talked about
with the government pressuring
big tech to do certain things
that the government
defines as misinformation.
That's dangerous.
So I want that
process speed it up.
But what I don't want,
and what makes me nervous is
because I think it would be
a worst situation is to
stead of having it go through
the court system
is to move it over
to the regulatory commission.
Because right now at the FTC,
the people who run the
FTC are radical leftists.
Becca Slaughter is a member
on the FTC commission.
She has said,
we should use antitrust law
to deal with systemic racism.
- [Dave] Yeah, yeah.
- You, and I would
say, no, we shouldn't.
And a hundred years
of anti-trust law
says, no we shouldn't.
So that scares me.
Lina Khan, who's the
new chairman of the FTC,
who, by the way,
when Biden nominated
and put up for nomination
front of the Senate,
didn't tell the senators,
which is historically the
way it's supposed to work.
But he didn't tell the senators
that he was going to
make her chairman.
Guess where she worked
before she went to
the FTC as chairman?
- She was worked for
Facebook or something right?
- Right she worked there,
but more importantly,
and more recently,
she worked for Jerry Nadler,
David Cicilline,
Hakeem Jeffries.
All the people who were
the impeachment managers
who put together these bills.
My guess is Lina
Khan wrote the bills.
They give all the power to
the agency she now chairs.
I don't think that's a
good thing for Dave Rubin,
who believes in
the first amendment
and Jim Jordan and the
folks I get to represent.
So that's my concern.
Let's let it work through
the court process,
but let's do it quicker because
as bad as it's
getting and the pace,
that big tech is going
to limit our freedoms,
I want an answer soon.
And I think justice
Thomas is with this.
My guess is the courts is with
this, 'cause they gotta be.
Coney, Amy Coney
Barrett, justice Alito.
They got to be concerned
with what they see
when the press secretary for
the United States president
steps up at the white house
briefing room and says,
we're working with Facebook
to take down people's posts
and take down information.
- So you basically see
the judicial branch.
I mean, in essence,
the Supreme court,
because that's where
this probably ends up.
You, see that as the
last firewall, right.
I mean, at that point,
if nothing else works.
And to your point, if you're,
if the whole middle
branch of government.
You know, if the
congressional branch
and all the regulatory people,
if they're all compromised,
it's judicial or nothing.
- Well, but we could do
something legislatively,
but frankly we're
not in control.
I mean, right now the
Democrats have the house,
they have the Senate,
they have the white house
and they're going to have
the white house until president
Trump runs and wins in 2024,
which I hope is what's
going to happen.
- Oh bold, bold.
So you think he's doing it?
You think he's doing it?
- I do and I've
encouraged him to.
I mean, I, every
time I talked to him,
I encourage him to run.
But the truth is we can't
change anything right now.
So all we can do is what you do.
We can highlight every
time they're infringing
on American's liberties.
And I do it at
every speech I give,
all across our district,
all across the country,
every time I'm out
talking, I talk about,
I just go to the
first amendment.
I said, think about
the first amendment.
The liberties you have
under the first amendment,
every single one of them has
been assaulted by government
over the past several years.
I mean, your right to
practice your faith,
your right to assemble,
your right to petition,
your government freedom of
the press, freedom of speech,
every single one.
I use the example,
when I went...
There's still churches
today, Dave, that probably,
well, my guess is in LA county.
They're probably still
churches today that
the full congregation can't
meet on Sunday morning.
And a few weeks,
this is probably now what
eight, nine, 10 weeks ago.
I spoke to, think about
your right to assemble.
I spoke to the New
Mexico Republican party
in Amarillo, Texas,
because they had to go
to Texas to get freedom.
They had to go to Texas to be
able to assemble in the size
they wanted to assemble
because their Democrat governor
wouldn't let them assemble more
than 149 people in the state
of New Mexico.
So that's crazy, but,
and on and on it goes.
So I think, I think this is,
this is the fundamental issue
and I mean, scares me to
death, scares me to death.
- So to that point.
How concerned are you
that just nobody trusts
the system anymore?
That's sort of where I'm
getting, which is, you know,
that's what the kids call
black pill that you just think
that the thing is so broken,
that nothing could be done.
And I always try to put a
positive spin on all this stuff,
and I want to do
solutions of course,
that's why I do this.
But I think a lot of people
are just like, you know what,
I don't trust the
medical experts
because of lockdowns
and masks anymore.
I don't trust the politicians
who say one thing
about elections,
when their guys in and
the other, the other way.
Like that, that
the whole system,
it only works if we trust it.
And a lot of people just
don't trust it anymore.
- Yeah. And I'm very
concerned about that.
And it's when you
have, and again,
I think most of the blame,
frankly, glides with what,
with the left.
The left is, has attacked
every institution we have.
And frankly, let's
just be honest,
the left controls almost
everything, right.
The left controls, big media,
the left controls big tech,
the left controls Hollywood,
the left controls
higher education,
big corporations.
The left now
controls big sports.
I mean, just watch
the NBA, right.
- I don't watch the NBA anymore.
- But the left controls
the Congress right now,
the left controls
the white house.
The one area they don't control,
and this is the beauty
of our great country.
The one thing they don't control
is they still don't
control individuals.
We the people still have
individual liberties,
individual rights, so we
can think for ourselves,
and express ourselves
and speak out.
But they're even
trying to stop that
with the whole cancel culture.
So, and finally,
maybe the one institution
that they still don't control
is state and local government.
And that's why, what
DeSantis is doing in Florida
with the Florida legislature,
what they're doing.
They're pushing back in
our Federalist system.
That's how the founders
and God blessed these individual
put our system together.
They're not only
checks and balances
with the separate and equal
branches of government.
There's the Federalist
system where the checks
and balances also
come from the states.
And that's where we
have to fight back now.
And we're having some
governors who are doing it.
And I think that's giving
some more courage
to other governors,
particularly other
Republican governors
to step up and act like the
DeSantis is doing in Florida
and push back on the crazy left
in the policies they want.
- You mentioned they
control the media too.
How much of your day to
day is just pushing back
on just the crazy stuff
that the media says
about not only you, but
just Republicans in general.
You know, obviously a
bunch of racist homophobes
and all that nonsense.
And you know, this will
shift us to another topic.
But you know, you're
passing bills.
You guys were always passing
bills to restrict voting.
And then you look
at the actual bill.
Not that the, not that
the media ever does it.
And you're like, oh,
well it causes, you know,
voter ID, that seems okay.
And you know, a paper
trail that seems okay.
Making sure we count
correctly, that seems okay.
But how much of your
day is just dealing
with that sort of nonsense?
- A fair amount.
I mean, you know, but
I tell my colleagues,
I tell guys in
the freedom caucus
and colleagues on the
judiciary committee.
I tell them, look,
if the press isn't
saying something bad,
the mainstream press.
If the press isn't saying
something bad about you,
you're not doing
anything any good.
So just under,
'cause some people come here
and they think like, oh,
they're not used to just
the relentless attack
you're going to get if
you're making a difference.
So it's a shock for some people.
But my attitude is you
have to embrace it because
that's just the way it is.
And it's not fun,
it's not pleasant.
And you just pushed back
by telling the truth.
I always tell people.
I think we make this job as
being a member of Congress,
we make it way too complicated.
What did you tell the
voters you were going to do
when you ran?
They elected you to
do that, go do it.
Make the argument,
make the case,
do it in as compelling and
articulate way as you can.
But go do that
and if you do that
and the press calls
you all kinds of names
and you're like you said,
your racist and were
terrible and evil and all.
Okay, fine. We
gotta, it's not fun.
But we got a live with it.
Just keep pressing on
because you're doing what
you told the voters
you're going to do.
And what I find is
when you go back home
voters appreciate it.
Even if they disagree with
you every once in a while,
they'll say, I just liked
the fact that you're fighting
and you're doing what you said.
I don't agree with all of it.
I agree with most of
it, but keep fighting.
And that's what we're
supposed to do, I think,
as a member of Congress.
- So what do you make of the
Republicans that I sort of,
at this point, you know,
I'm kind of new to
this side, right.
So I maybe have
fresh eyes on this.
But you know, when I see
a guy like Mitt Romney
or someone like Liz Cheney,
I call them pet Republicans
because they go on MSNBC,
they get pat on the head,
like they're doing anything.
And then in essence,
they're Democrats.
Now that's fine if that's what
they believe at this point.
But when you guys get behind
closed doors, like, are you,
do you say to them, hey,
is there any
conservative principle?
Is there any piece of
the Republican party
that you guys are
here to defend,
or is it just so that they're
nice to you on cable news?
- Yeah. I just,
I never get that.
I never get why some people
want to go be the
Republican who attacks
all the other Republicans.
I mean, once in a while
you're going to have some
squabbles, I get that,
that's just normal
course of business.
But there's some Republicans
who want to go on TV
and just attack Republicans.
And of course, CNN will
love you for a day,
love you for a minute,
love you for a second.
But as soon as you're
not doing that,
then they're going to turn
around and start attacking you.
And I never get like,
don't you see that?
Don't, haven't you figured
out that they just,
it doesn't take a genius
to figure this out.
But yet you have
some people who,
who think their job
is to be the darling
of CNN and attack Republicans.
I just never understood it.
- Yeah. So, all right.
So one other thing on big tech,
and then we'll move on to
some of the other stuff.
Are you worried at all,
this is sort of an extension
of the black pill question.
But just that this stuff has
become so big that no matter
what you do, no matter
what you do at this point,
that do you think it's
possible that the ship
has just sailed and the
government cannot do anything?
- Look I'm concerned,
I'm nervous.
I mean, don't misunderstand.
I think, I think
it just, you know,
obviously with the
question you asked,
you have that you share
that same concern.
But I mean,
I always come back to
like, this is America,
we're Americans,
we get things done.
We've solved problems. We've
tackled all kinds of obstacles.
I mean, you know, there's a,
there's some people who make
the case that, you know,
it's just this tough, rugged
attitude is in our DNA.
You know, you think about the
people who started this place.
Over in Europe, they said,
you gotta practice your
faith a certain way.
And they said, no, we don't.
We'll get on the ship,
we'll risk it all.
We'll go to this place called
America and we're going to do
it the way we think
we need to do it
and the way the good
Lord wants us to do it.
And they did it and
we've overcome everything
and become the
greatest country ever.
So I still feel like
there's a ton of people
who think like you and I do.
Who think like the
folks I get to represent
back in the fourth
district of Ohio.
Who are willing to say,
no, we're not going
to let it happen.
We're going to fight.
We're going to do what
it takes in the right way
to prevail in the end
for freedom, for liberty,
for free speech.
So I guess I'm optimistic.
And maybe it's just
because I'm, you know,
like you I'm American,
and I love the way we,
we conquer things
to get things done.
- Well I always tell people
I'm a world weary optimist.
Because I'm an optimist,
I don't think I could
do this if I wasn't.
How could you say what
you think for a living
if you were an optimist.
But I'm also a realist.
So that, that gives you
a little world weary.
But to that point,
though, if there,
if there are enough of us
or let's say there's
more of us than them.
What do we do about some
of this election stuff?
Because it seems to me.
I played a clip on
the show last week,
which was a compilation
of Democrats in 2018,
including Kamala and
Klobuchar. You probably saw it.
- Oh yeah.
- It's about 15 Democrats
talking about rigged elections,
talking about voting
machines that don't work,
talking about hacking.
All of the stuff that
I'm pretty sure you and I
could get blown up here on
YouTube, right this very moment
for talking about if
we talk about it now.
- Right, right.
'Cause Dave, you
forgot only Democrats
are allowed to object
to election results.
We can't object.
- I always have to
make a note about that.
- We're not allowed to.
I mean, you think
about the folks on
this January 6th commission
on the Democrat side.
Bennie Thompson objected
to the election results
in 2001 when president Bush won.
Jamie Raskin, the lead
impeachment manager,
and impeachment round two,
he objected to Florida
and on January 6th, 2017.
Jim McGovern, Jim McGovern
on the day we had this,
the second impeachment debate
on the floor on January 13th,
he brought up the week
before January 6th.
And he said,
Republicans objected
to the will of the people
last week when they
try to overturn the will of
people and they objected.
So I got up to speak right
after that and I said, well,
you know, I said, I
said the fine gentlemen,
the chairman of
the rules committee
from Massachusetts, Mr.
McGovern said that we,
we try to overturn
the will of people.
I said, but guess who was
the first person to object
on January 6th, 2017?
Guess who was the first person?
- I got an idea.
- It was the right fine
gentleman from Massachusetts
who objected to Alabama.
Think about that Dave.
Alabama, president Trump
won by like 28 points.
So he can object to Alabama,
but Jim Jordan and Republicans
can't object to Pennsylvania
where they unconstitutionally
changed their election law.
I mean think about
this one fact.
The election law passed
by the legislature,
as the constitution requires
in Pennsylvania said
election ends at
eight o'clock Tuesday.
You know I mean of course,
election day is
always on Tuesday.
First Tuesday, after the
first Monday in November,
it ends at eight
o'clock Tuesday.
Democrats sued in the
partisan state Supreme court
and the partisan
state Supreme court
controlled by
Democrats says, nope,
we don't care what
the legislature said.
We don't care what the law says.
Election day now ends
at five o'clock Friday.
They just extended the
election for three days.
So I'm not allowed
to object to that.
But Jim McGovern can
object to Alabama
when Donald Trump wins
Alabama by 28 points.
You gotta be kidding me.
So that's the part that drives.
And it is my guess is you
spend a lot of your time doing
the same thing I do,
pointing out the freaking double
standard with these people.
But you have to do
it because if not,
they'll get away with it more.
- Let's not forget. I think
his name is Josh Shapiro,
the secretary of
state of Pennsylvania,
who announced two days
before the election,
that Biden was going
to win Pennsylvania
before the election.
- Yeah. The guy
counting the votes
announces two days before
who's going to win.
Maybe there's a problem with it.
I mean call me crazy, call me.
But they may be, there may be.
You know, but of
course Democrats
like all you guys are crazy.
Somehow we're the conspiracy
theorist for just like,
just like raising a
question about that.
- So what do you guys
do on messaging them?
Because I'm not kidding.
I went through the
nine bullet points
in the last Texas bill,
you know, on the
election that the HB3
that they were going crazy over.
And it really,
it was things like ID.
It was a paper trail.
It was having cameras
when you're counting
and a couple of very,
very basic things.
There was nothing race in there.
There was nothing to
stop anyone from voting.
There were actually things like
actually extending benefits
so employers could give more
time for people to vote.
And yet it's called racist.
It's repeated in
associated press
and on NBC and everything else.
Like how do you
beat that narrative?
- You know, I think, well
again, you put out the facts,
you do like, you
did. But I also...
- Yeah, I'm past that point.
What else do you
do besides that?
- I think Americans get it.
So take this, take this,
the Texas Democrats.
So first of all,
America sees Texas Democrats
getting on a private plane,
you know, taking their
football and going home,
not doing their
job, come into it.
You know, this is emblematic
of what the Democrats think.
I'm going to not do my job
and I'm going to go to
Washington where I can say
I'm a victim.
That is like so Democrat, right.
So they come to Washington,
they spread COVID around
to everybody else.
They found a plane with no mask.
They probably had to show.
So I think sometimes just
the common sense of Americans
like these people are crazy.
And I am convinced six months
into this administration,
the worst six months start
to any administration
in my lifetime.
I'm convinced so many
Americans are like, well,
maybe, maybe, maybe I
didn't bargain for this.
Maybe this is,
maybe I should have voted
for president Trump.
You know, some of these people
who, for whatever reason,
decided not to vote
for president Trump,
who was such a great president,
and they vote for Biden.
I think they're like,
buyer's remorse big time.
They're like filling up
their gas tank, whoa,
this is costing a lot more.
Price of eggs, bread, milk,
lumber, price of TV's price,
price of an airline
ticket price of a hotel
everything's up and
crime in the streets.
And oh by the way,
March was the highest month
on record of illegal crossings
at our Southern border
until April and April was
the highest month until May
and May was the highest
month until June.
That's what you call a trend
in a very bad direction.
So I think all that they're
like saying this, this is.
So I think that that's how it
gets through is like Americans
have common sense and
they're figuring it out.
- Congressmen just to be clear
they're not kids
in cages anymore.
They're young people
in funds centers.
- Exactly, exactly.
- I've been down
there, it's exactly...
- Since I can tell, you're
not holding back today,
you just mentioned Biden.
I mean, what do you think is
really going on with Biden?
He is not all there.
That's my professional
diagnosis.
- Well, you know, look.
You know, it's in some
ways, it's a big concern.
Because as much as we talk about
all the issues we've talked
about in the end, you know,
our adversaries see the
same thing that we see.
And, you know, you saw,
oh this is probably
three months ago
when our secretary of state
secretary Blinken was in Alaska,
in Anchorage meeting with
his Chinese counterpart.
And, you know,
we had our team on
one side of the table
and they had the Chinese
on the other side.
And the treatment that the
Chinese gave to the secretary
of state of the United
States of America.
I'm like, I mean, it
was, it was embarrassing.
And then, and frankly,
you didn't see secretary
Blinken really pushed back.
It's like, if that happened.
Well, first of all,
that would not happen in
a Trump administration
to Mike Pompeo.
But if it did,
if they were crazy
enough to say those kinds
of things to Pompeo.
I know, I know
Mike, he had got up,
like maybe he flipped the table
over, or he would've got up.
Or he would have said
with all due respect,
that is entirely wrong.
You don't talk to.
It would have, there
would have been pushback,
real pushback, like you're
supposed to do in real diplomacy
when you come from a
position of strength.
And it didn't
happen and I'm like.
Now we see China,
what they said to Japan
just a couple of days ago.
And now we see what Putin is
saying about any type of things
we're going to put in Europe.
I'm like, that's what happens
when you don't project strength.
And when you have a
commander-in-chief,
you have a present United States
who was behaving in the
way president Biden is.
And, it's dangerous for
not only the United States
and our security, but
frankly for our allies
and how things
work in the world.
And that's, that's
troubling, I think.
And obviously you see it.
And then I think so
many Americans do.
Do hear that from counterparts
in other countries?
Because my belief,
although the media
won't show it this way.
My belief is that other
most certainly Western
European countries,
but I think most of Europe,
I think most of South America,
I actually think
most of the world,
they want us to be strong.
They want us to lead.
- Of course. of course they do.
Now they may go well because
of the liberal press.
And, after a world leader
meets with president Trump,
my guess is behind the
scenes they're saying, hey,
keep it up, keeps it, you
know, they appreciate it.
Then they'll go out and
they'll do the liberal stuff
and they'll say bad things
about president Trump.
But they appreciate
it when America.
I always say this,
the world's a safer and
better place when we lead.
And you can't lead militarily
and diplomatically,
unless you lead economically.
And right now the Democrats
are doing everything wrong.
Think about, just
think about economics.
Democrats locked down states.
Democrats spend like crazy.
Democrats pay
Americans not to work
and then for those
who are working,
they're getting ready
to raise your taxes.
Now that's four of the
dumbest ideas I've ever heard,
but that's what they're
doing economically.
So that is going to
hurt our chance to lead
both diplomatically militarily.
Because the way this world
operates is you better
be the economic superpower
if you're going to
be the military,
so they work together.
And that's the part
that scares me.
So, yeah.
- But do you think, do you
think it's just too much
of a jump to say
that in essence,
the Democrats right
now are basically
just doing China's bidding.
I mean, if you keep
locking us down,
keep wrecking our economy,
keeping making sure
that we don't go to
meetings and put, you know,
a strong posture out there.
That we make it clear that China
can basically do
whatever they want.
The Chinese gotta
be pretty happy.
Plus there was some stuff
on hunter Biden's laptop,
which I'm not sure if
we're allowed to talk
about that anymore, that
they might have on Biden.
I mean, there's just a,
it's just a whole mess.
- No, it is.
I don't, I mean, I don't want
to think it's that, you know,
that we're, that we got
people in our government
doing things, you
know, in that way.
I just think that you got--
- I had Kevin McCarthy in studio
a couple of weeks ago,
and he said for sure
that Eric Swalwell
has been compromised
by a Chinese spy.
And he said, Nancy
Pelosi knows it.
Okay. He's the minority
leader of the house,
like, is he lying to me?
- No, but he gets
briefings that I don't get.
I mean, I was on
the intel committee
for a few months back during
the first impeachment.
So I don't get the briefings
that that leader McCarthy gets.
So, I mean, if that's
what Kevin said,
I believe him a hundred percent.
It's just, I just think that
we got so many members now in,
you know, members of Congress,
members of the gov and
people in the government
who are willing to do what
the radical left says.
It's just like, they've taken
over the Democrat party.
And you said it earlier, Dave,
and I think this is so true.
We now have the,
the bulk of one of the
major political parties
in our country who
thinks the country's bad.
I mean like that,
I mean, I've my,
my background's in the
sport of wrestling.
I've been to Cuba
twice. I've been to the,
what was then the Soviet Union.
And I tell people, you
go to places like that,
you thank the good
Lord you live here.
I was joking when I said.
I was in Moscow in February,
Moscow in February it's
like 400 below zero, man.
You thank the good Lord.
And the food was
terrible. And Cuba was--
- And those are the best parts.
- Yeah, and Cuba was
a warm Soviet union.
And I always tell folks,
it's not about the people,
the Cuban people were great,
the great athletes that,
the Russian people.
But when you have a system
that doesn't, doesn't value,
freedom and rule of law
and private property rights
and bad things happen.
So now we have a major
political party in the country
where you have a bunch of
leftists who think our country,
where we have all those things,
private property rights rule
of law, freedom, liberty.
They think all that's
bad and they want to,
and they want to put all
their authoritarian baloney
on the rest of us.
That's the problem.
And that's why we have
to fight back in a,
in the most compelling and
articulate way that we can.
- So speaking of
authoritarian baloney
you said to me right before
we started this thing,
'cause you know, I'm
out here in Cali.
You said, how long are you
going to stay out there?
I mean, just in
the last week or so
we suddenly have an
indoor mask mandate again.
It's done by one
middle-management bureaucrat.
I have no idea
where the mayor is.
As you know, we're in the midst
of the recall of the governor.
Thank the good Lord.
But do you think
that any of the,
do you think this stuff is
going to stop at any point,
or does the government now
just have the idea of COVID?
So that at any point,
any authoritarian in
any of these blue states
can just be like, yeah,
we're locking you down again.
Yeah, we're putting
masks on you again,
and God knows what
comes down the pipe.
- Yeah. I think Democrats
might try some of that.
They may even try, I mean,
the speaker may try it
here and they may put
the mask mandate back
on members of Congress.
You know, even though
probably, you know,
just about every single
member of Congress
has probably already
been vaccinated.
But so, but I tend to,
I go back to the
optimistic point
that we were talking
about earlier.
I think Americans have had it.
I know the folks I represent,
in the fourth district of Ohio,
west central,
north central Ohio.
They're like, ain't no way.
Ain't no way I'm going
back to all that baloney.
They're going to do that
tomorrow, our business,
our small business, our
company, and I'm going to.
There's no way Mike DeWine is
going to make me wear a mask
and do all that. It's
just not going to,
I just don't see it happening.
And I think you're going
to see state after state.
And a lot of these
governors saw that when
governor DeSantis and some
other governors stood up,
took a principal position and
then it played out in look
like, you know, their
economy was stronger.
They didn't have
any worst COVID,
and in many cases they
had better COVID numbers.
I think a lot of
these governors, like,
you know what,
DeSantis did it, right.
We're going to do more of that.
So I think the people in this
country going to say time out,
we're not going there again.
I don't care what
Dr. Fauci says,
I don't care what they say.
We're going to,
we're smart people.
We're Americans. We
believe in Liberty.
We understand COVID is serious.
We understand it's real.
But we'll deal with
it in the right way.
We're not going to
shut down our business.
We're not going to wear a mask.
We're not going to
shut down our schools.
- Can you just talk a little
bit about what it was like,
sort of more towards
the beginning of COVID,
when everything's breaking,
nobody knows exactly
what's going on,
two weeks to flatten the curve.
I'm sure you're there
with the governor.
You're there with
some of the mayors,
with other Congress people.
You're trying to
figure out what to do.
Like, I guess it's
different in every state.
But you know,
is it the governor that's
usually deciding this stuff
or are they just handing it over
to these middle
management people?
I mean, we had, you know,
there's this famous woman here
in LA Sheila Kuehl who voted.
She was the deciding
vote three to two
to close outdoor dining.
And then what'd she do,
right after she voted,
she goes out to eat
in Santa Monica.
And it's like,
those are the people
we've really had it with
because no one knew
this woman beforehand.
- Yeah. No, I know that,
that double standard Polosi
going into the salon,
when we couldn't.
Gavin Newsome going to
a five-star restaurant,
when he told us we
couldn't have Thanksgiving
with our family.
I mean, that's the
kind of stuff that,
excuse me, drives
Americans crazy.
But yeah, when it,
first started, there was
I think some concern,
but in many, in our state, it
was the governor working along
with the health
director, Dr. Acton.
And they seem to be
running everything.
And our, God bless
our general assembly.
In the end, they
finally, it took a while,
but they finally pushed back
and they pass
legislation that said,
if the governor is going to
put in some emergency order,
it's for a specified
period of time.
And then the general assembly
has to sign off on it
if it's going to go any further
and the governor vetoed it
and they overrode
the governor's veto.
So that's what we need more
of in some of these states
where governors
were doing things
and not following
the constitution.
- Yeah. If I'm not mistaken,
Newsome gave himself
unlimited emergency powers.
I mean, he's Palpatine
from Star Wars.
I don't know if I can make a
Star Wars reference with you.
I think I can.
But that, that in
essence is what he is.
All right. Let's talk about
a couple other things.
So, you know, there's this
January 6th commission.
You know, most of my audience,
I think is probably
where you are with this,
which is that we've
watched two years of riots
in the streets everywhere,
burning down our cities and
attacking federal courthouses
and all of that.
And we had Democrats
literally bailing people out
and doing nothing and
lawlessness everywhere.
But they've got their thing.
They've got their insurrection
and they want hearings and
they want to spy on more
people now because of it
and sensor more of us
and everything else.
What's your take on
just the whole thing?
- You're right. This
is, this is the,
this is impeachment round three.
They are obsessed with
going after president Trump.
They're going to do it again.
There's a fundamental question
that needs to be answered,
but my guess is Democrats on
the committee won't address it.
And that is why was there not
a proper security presence
and posture that day?
Because that's the
speaker's responsibility.
My guess is they don't
want to go there.
There was all kinds
of information.
They knew there was
going to be a big rally.
It wasn't any secret President
Trump was having a rally.
Why not have the proper
security presence here
for an important day like
January 6th, where you,
where you count and
certify the electoral votes
from each state.
So I don't know that
they'll go there.
I think this is driven by the
fact that we talked earlier.
What else they're
gonna talk about?
They gonna talk
about crime going up
in every major urban area.
They're going to talk about the
price of everything going up
on every single good and
service you can think of.
They're going to talk
about the border situation.
So they're going to talk about,
they're getting
ready to raise taxes.
They're going to talk about.
I mean, they're gonna
to talk about the fact
they're going to keep
spending, spending, spending,
driving a price, even higher.
I mean, what else do
they got to talk about?
So they're going to do this
and they're going to attack
the president 'cause
that's all they got.
I mean, what is it
CNN's ratings now
are down so far
because, because,
and yet they're still
talking about Trump.
But they can't do it in the
same way they did before.
So they've been obsessed with
going after president Trump
and here they go again,
'cause that's the only thing
they got in their playbook.
- Congressman you forget
that Joe Biden tweeted out
that the average
American saves 16 cents
on their July 4th cookout.
That's pretty good.
16 cents.
But you know,
you've mentioned the second
impeachment a couple of times.
Just real quick on that. Did
anyone think that it was legit?
I mean, even I know
how you felt about it,
but did any of the
Democrats, at that point,
there was no support
for it in the country,
except in the most
radical left corners.
Did anyone think it was legit?
- Well the hard lefties
in the Congress, sure.
Just like the hard lefties
around the country.
But you're right in the rest
of the country was like,
what are you doing,
he's not even.
He's leaving office
in a few days
and the trial actually
took place after
he was out of office, so.
Yeah, but that's when you,
when it's an obsession.
I mean, it was, it's truly an
obsession with these folks.
And I, you know,
I remember when I first heard
the term Trump
derangement syndrome.
I'm like wow, well,
you know, whatever.
But you've, I'm sure you've
been around people who are like,
no, it's a, it's a thing.
People just get like, consumed
with being against
president Trump.
And it's, it's sometimes
it's tough on families.
You know, we got,
we got relatives who are
like, most of them are,
most of them are not, most
of them love president Trump.
They're like me, they love
what he did for the country.
But others are like, whoa,
and you're just like, oh,
I never saw that coming.
But some people it just hit them
and they can't, they
can't shake it loose.
- Yeah. So on the Trump run.
I mean, you, obviously were
and are one of his big allies.
Was there anything that you
tried to get him to soften on
or change on or message
differently that he didn't,
that you think
might've hurt him?
- No. I mean, well,
when president Trump first
came into office, Paul Ryan
put forward the Obamacare
repeal legislation, terrible,
terrible, terrible approach.
And I thought the wrong bill.
We should have just
done what we'd pass back
in the end of 2016.
What we campaigned on, we
should have just passed that.
That's what Mitch
McConnell want to do,
because he had the votes
in the Senate to pass that,
we passed it in the house.
Should have brought
up the same bill.
Paul Ryan decides no,
we're going to do this
three bucket approach.
We're going to do
part of it here,
then we're going to do some of
it through regulatory reform.
I'm like, what are
you talking about?
So I oppose the Ryan healthcare
appeal because it was bad.
It wasn't what we told the
voters we were going to do.
And president Trump
was new to office.
He was actually, he actually
supported what Paul was doing.
And then once that went through,
then Mark Meadows went to
work and we got another bill
that pass, pass the house,
that was much more consistent
with what we told the
voters we're going to do.
And unfortunately we all
remember when John McCain gave
the thumbs down
and it didn't pass.
But I think that's
through that process
where we were actually
opposed to what,
what the speaker was doing
and what the white
house was supporting.
I think president
Trump learned like, oh,
you can count on these guys.
They're going to
stick with stuff.
And then Mark and I just became,
we just got to know the
president and we so appreciated
his doing what he
said he would do.
I mean that's what
the freedom caucus is,
our mission statement.
We talked about doing
what we told the voters
we're going to do, that's
what president Trump did.
And we went to bat for
him 'cause he did it.
I mean, you just
think about this.
Every single
presidential candidate,
both Republican and Democrat
over the last several cycles
for most of my lifetime
have said, if you elect me,
I will put the
embassy in Jerusalem.
They've all said it.
They get elected.
And then they come up
with a bazillion reasons
why they can't do what they
said they were going to do,
and frankly, what they
were elected to do.
President Trump gets
elected and he goes,
I'm going to do it.
All the state
department people said,
well, Mr. president,
you better not do that.
You know what all
the concerns are.
He goes, I told the
people I'm going to do it.
I'm going to do it.
He did it and it
worked out fine.
So that is what I so
appreciated about this guy.
And we need a lot more, frankly,
like him willing to do what
they said in elective office.
- Yeah. So you've mentioned
DeSantis a couple of times.
I mean, obviously you like him.
One of the things that
I've been saying is, look,
if DeSantis runs to me,
we need some young blood.
I think he's only 40, 42 or 43.
I mean, it would be
a generational shift.
And that may be Trump
acts as the body guard.
He still takes all the hits.
He deals with all
the media nonsense,
but then it allows
for just a change.
Because we act, we need
to change if nothing else
than just for age and just
that we need to move forward.
You know, that sort of sounds,
it almost sounds pie in the sky.
But we just need, we
just need some new blood.
But it sounds like you
want Trump either way,
even when you like DeSantis.
- Oh, yeah I want
president Trump.
I think first of all, I think,
again, as I've said a
few times, no one was,
no one has proven that
they can take as much heat
and as much intensity
as president Trump took
and still get so much done,
still do so much
of what he said.
So I definitely am
for president Trump.
I want him to run
that's who I'm for.
If he chooses not to,
you're right Ron DeSantis
would be a great.
Ron DeSantis, there
was nine of us
who started the freedom caucus,
Ron was one of the nine.
Ron has been rock solid in
what he's done in Florida,
sticking to his guns.
And plus I always tell
folks, it doesn't,
it never hurts to be smart.
Ron DeSantis is a smart guy.
He's a smart guy.
It never hurts to
have smart people.
And if you got smart
people who are principled,
who were in positions of
leadership, even better.
So I think that's who
president Trump is.
I think that's who
Ron DeSantis is.
But I want president
Trump to run.
I am a hundred percent for him.
I think he's our best candidate.
But if he doesn't, Ron
DeSantis would be great.
- Yeah.
What else has been on your mind?
I'm going to give you
a general one here.
Like just what else is sort
of running through your mind
as you're doing your job these
days and all the craziness.
- Fauci knew on
January 31st, 2020
at 10:32 PM.
He gets an email from
Dr. Christian Anderson,
one of these virologists
who's, who had received
our tax dollar, your tax money,
my constituents tax money.
Received our tax
dollars, doing research.
He sends an email to Dr. Fauci
10:32, January 31st, 2020
and he says, the virus
looks engineered,
it's not consistent with
evolutionary theory.
So Anthony Fauci is on notice
clear back at the early
in the first month of 2020
that this virus came
from the lab most likely,
looks engineered, not consistent
with evolutionary theory.
He didn't jump from
an animal to human.
He's on notice and what does
he do over the next year?
Downplays that tells
us something different.
And so to me, that that is like,
you're the highest paid
official in our government.
You're the, you're
on every talk show,
you're covered every day,
your Time Magazine person
of the, you know, the
the greatest person
on the planet
for the last thousand years,
whatever they gave him.
And like, and you're
misleading the American people.
And there's things
that happen after that.
Emails that happened
that reinforced
that I think he knew early on.
By February 1st, the next day,
I think he knew there was a
lethal virus on the loose.
There's been gained a
function research funded
at the Wuhan
Institute of Virology.
That gain of function research
didn't go through the
P three framework,
the oversight framework.
And I got an email from
one of the virologist
who is an expert in this area,
who says the virus
looks engineered,
not consistent with
evolutionary theory.
He knew all that
on February 1st.
- Do you think he's
actually in trouble
for lying to Congress?
I mean, that's what Rand Paul
was really trying to get him
on in the last couple of days,
in effect saying, hey,
you said that the NIH
funding did not have anything
to do with this virus being
engineered in the Wuhan lab.
And now it kind of
looks like it is.
He was, his answer
was very confusing
because he basically
was sort of saying,
well, we funded some stuff,
not necessarily that study.
And you know, he gave him a lot
of bureaucratic doublespeak.
- And a sub-grant through
EcoHealth, blah, blah, blah.
It's like it was American
tax dollars going through
EcoHealth, going to the
Wuhan Institute of Virology.
So look at the email he sent.
He gets that 10:32 email from
Dr. Christian Anderson saying,
it looks engineer not consented
with evolutionary theory.
Two hours later,
12:38 in the morning.
He sends an email to his top
assistant Dr. Austin Kloss,
who has worked for
him for like 16 years.
He sends an email
that says, Hugh,
keep your phone on.
Important task You
will have to do.
Read this paper
that I've attached.
It was like, you know, the
house on fire kind of email.
And that, the paper he attached
was an article written by Dr.
Shi, the so-called Batwoman
in Wuhan China,
where they're talking about
gain of function research.
So Dr. Austin Kloss,
11 hours later,
gets back to Dr. Fauci,
11:47 AM the next morning,
February 1st gets back and says,
gain a function
research was happened.
It didn't go through
the P three framework.
I will look to see if
we have any ties to it.
In other words,
I'll look to see if
what we need to do
to cover our backside.
That, that to me tells a lot.
And now, again, maybe
I'm misinterpreting,
I'm just reading the emails.
Maybe I'm wrong
about the emails.
But Dr. Fauci,
he doesn't want to come
testify in front of us anymore.
The select committee
on the coronavirus.
Democrats won't invite him in.
We invited him in
Republicans, wouldn't come.
He goes into every
TV show, testifies.
He testified I think like 18
times in front of Congress,
but won't come in
front of us again.
I'd love the question
one more time.
- Right, and then of course,
there's that email from,
I think it was February
or March where he just
has a friend emailing
him about, you know,
she's going on vacation and
does she have to wear masks.
And he basically says, well,
if you buy the mask at a store,
it doesn't work anyway.
- Yeah. I mean the
misinformation. I
mean, think about that.
They're going after us for miss,
or for other people
for misinformation,
but the misinformation we've
received from the government
and from the mainstream
press on so many issues,
as you pointed out earlier,
it's just ridiculous.
- Yeah. all right. On
that, on that note,
and that was a professional
cough you did right there.
You didn't do it in the
hand, you went this way.
On that note,
if people want to pay
attention to the big tech stuff
that you're working on,
where can we send them?
Because I think people
are just like, hey,
I want to help somehow,
doesn't even mean with dollars.
I just want to know what's
going on and what bills
I should support and
that sort of thing.
- Yeah. Go to the judiciary
committee website.
We will have
information up there.
We have the principals up there.
We're trying to put
them in bill form.
We want to get there soon.
But go to the judiciary website.
I don't know. I mean, our,
our media people and our
staff know what that is, but.
- There's a lot of dots.
All the government websites,
they don't look
that good frankly.
That would be, you want
to be your major job.
You get them to rehash it,
redo all of those
government websites.
- Yeah.
- Congressman I appreciate,
I appreciate your time.
- No I've had a
good time. Thanks.
- Keep up the good
fight we need,
we need to fix
some of this stuff.
- You keep it up and we
need, we need defenders,
like you out there talking
about protecting Americans'
liberties and specifically
the first amendment.
So God bless you.
- I got nothing better to
do than save the world.
- Thanks, man.
- Thank you.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety
of topics, watch our
full episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.